so yes this is your dining area
Canadians aiming to purchase a home this
year have a lot of decisions to juggle
what kind of property how much they're
willing to spend and how they will
finance one of the largest purchases
they will ever make the options are now
changing it is a really good time to get
a lower interest rate than you would
have been getting for the last year with
fixed rates starting to come down
Brokers are warning against locking in
longer term mortgages this with interest
rates expected to drop with a cooling
bond market which the bank Canada uses
as its Benchmark you definitely do want
to ask for other options from your
lender maybe a three-year rate maybe a
variable 5year rate uh you might want to
see what other options exist out there
housing affordability is an issue from
coast to coast and critics are
questioning ottawa's actions on
addressing these issues Justin Trudeau's
policies whether it's printing money or
funding government Gatekeepers that
block Home Building or failing to make
the link between the number of homes and
the and the population growth have
doubled housing costs the prime minister
laid out how the housing crisis needs to
be tackled on multiple fronts to address
these issues but anyone looking to
secure a mortgage on a home now will
have to consider the long-term costs if
you lock in for 5 years it's going to
cost you you know depending on your
mortgage uh size is thousands of dollars
more if the market is correct Kyle
Benning Global News